hey I'm Batman whoa it's open you had
more steak but uh a lot of these crazy
pop things they're so good nice to have
you at my house again it's great I know
I don't have a lot of steak in the
fridge but welcome as much as you want
almost as good as the secreto because
there's a chance an opera house so did
you catch the MTV Awards last night
what show I would never watch that show
that's just stupid and dumb dude your
trailer man it aired on the MTV Awards
there's like a big thing it was like the
whole hook of the show is introduced by
Christopher Nolan anything I know it's
crazy I was surprised that we're even
there it was really the only reason to
watch the show in fact I'm pretty sure
it's the only reason anyone wants the
show the show is just overrun with
Twilight propaganda and brought a
placement for things like The Hunger
Games I have no reason to watch it
either but I'll be the only thing that
made me actually do it I mean it you
could see best fight was given to the
Hunger Games and not Mission Impossible
Ghost Protocol or warrior I mean it you
can see Warrior II was incredible
hey man I don't do the votes I'll do the
nominations the only reason they even
watch the show is cuz of your trailer
okay at least tell me the Twilight
didn't win Best Picture
just tell me that drive ya drive was
nominated for a movie of the year
definitely it really was yeah so was
Rise of the Planet of the Apes and super
8 in Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol
and everything yeah it wasn't Twilight
breaking down or anything
Oh God
hey there's always next year Dark Knight
Rises we'll probably nominated for next
year's show
I'm gonna go so I wasn't really planning
on talking about the Dark Knight Rises
trailer that aired with the MTV Movie
Awards because as a general rule I don't
like to mention that show ever in my
life or in my channel I try not to but
so many people have actually already
sent me messages and requests on
Facebook and Twitter and YouTube just be
like hey are you gonna talk about it and
so I decided you know what if you want
to see it here it is I'm going to try
not to talk about that show too much
that's right I'm not gonna talk about
how josh hutcherson won Best Male
performance over Ryan Gosling and
driving Joseph gordon-levitt in 50/50
I'm not going to talk about how the
final fight in Hunger Games beat the
final fight in Mission Impossible Ghost
Protocol and the final fight in warrior
I'm not going to talk about that I'm not
going to talk about how the kiss between
Ryan Gosling and Emma Stone and Crazy
Stupid Love was nominated over the kiss
between Ryan Gosling and Carey Mulligan
and drive clearly a better kiss much
better kiss just saying it was a better
kiss and I most certainly am NOT going
to talk about how the nominations for
movie of the year featured movies from
last year and this year and how the
winner was Twilight Breaking Dawn men
talking about that
however sitting through that show was
semi worth it because I was introduced
to a new clip from The Dark Knight Rises
it was a brand new trailer this was
introduced by Christian Bale Gary Oldman
Joseph gordon-levitt and Christopher
Nolan before they showed up they showed
a montage from Batman Begins in the dark
night and when Heath Ledger came on
Christian Bale actually started crying
and he couldn't really contain himself
for a second and I was actually really
touched by that I was really surprised
and moved by that I thought that was
really special and we got to see a new
trailer for The Dark Knight Rises and I
was skeptical because to me it seemed
like it was just a hook to get people to
watch the MTV Awards because it was like
hey it's coming up it's coming up it's
coming up it's really the only reason
you're watching this show just want to
let you know but Thank You Nolan once
again you've given us a great trailer
without spoiling any plot points I love
you you got to see Bane forcing this guy
to sit down in front of like hundreds of
people he looks very worried and Bane is
like kneeling before him you're like
what is he gonna do to this guy in
public
and Hathaway is talking about how you
really need to be afraid of bein that
she's basically on the run from him that
she just wants to stay away from him
entirely Joseph gordon-levitt is sitting
there questioning her about him you see
Christian Bale I take a punch toward
Bain he just like catches it and Bain
looks like he's about to rip off
Batman's head you really get a sense
that they are turning pain into a very
terrifying villain there's a little
tribute to Batman Begins in this trailer
the guy turns around Batman's upside
down behind him and he's like okay here
I'm wondering if you're gonna see more
connections with this movie with the
other two films that really wrap up the
whole trilogy with these trailers the
thing that I'm really starting to buy is
Catwoman because she was really the
thing I was most skeptical about at
first but as I'm seeing more footage of
her more line readings from Anne
Hathaway I'm really getting excited for
her Jonathan Nolan commented that Anne
is just absolutely great in the film
she's really a scene stealer as you guys
know I am dying to see this movie I
can't wait to see it I put the link for
the trailer below it's definitely my
most anticipated film of the year if you
want to check that trailer it's in the
description and as always guys if you
like this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck mine eyes